mike florio of pro football talk joining
us right here on this edition of the
rich eisen show 10 days from the nfl
draft how are you mike
i'm doing great rich how are you i'm
wonderful how do you think
um this super league news is
uh hit 345 park avenue with uh the
owners
of uh arsenal and manchester united
coming from a membership in the nfl
arsenal being owned by stan kroenke
and uh manchester united owned by the
reigning
defending super bowl champion buccaneer
owners the glazers your thoughts
i'll freely admit that my only knowledge
of international soccer comes from
periodically playing the fifa game
which is an excellent game a nice break
from madden from time to time
over saturated on madden but there's so
many leagues and it's so hard to follow
and i like the idea
of all the best teams being collected in
one group apparently fifa doesn't like
that idea
nobody's an intrigue not a lot of human
beings do who aren't going to be
made very rich about this i guess my
question would be is
you know this this could would never
happen with the national football
because you're already hearing well this
is what would happen if the patriots and
the packers and the steelers all decided
to get together
and uh and separate you know like that
would uh that's
that's the just a couple of sense on
that subject three key words
broadcast and i trust exemption if and
when
the thing under the law that keeps the
nfl from getting sued by
selling its tv rights is one block so if
you want the cowboys
you also have to take the insert name of
least desirable team
at any given moment i don't want to
gratuitously i'll deliberately
piss off a fan base i don't want to do
it gratuitously but
if that ever goes away and it becomes
like it is with notre dame like it would
be with jerry jones selling his rights
which him
surely he'd love to do sell cowboys
rights
only and the other team sell their
rights only i think the disparity in
revenue
would be so dramatic that something like
that
could kind of organically and
spontaneously happen that's years down
the road but with streaming
streaming's not broadcast and there are
some interesting legal questions are
going to pop up over the next 15 or 20
years
about the nfl potentially violating
antitrust laws and what that would mean
and how that would spin out with the
haves and the have-nots
and the the teams that can generate huge
money
on tv deals that they would cut
themselves
as opposed to the teams that would be
scrounging for whatever they could find
that would be the catalyst
for something like this where you could
see the nfl split the two leagues the
super league
and a glorified minor league that that
that's not impossible
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
i guess let's talk about the here and
now then
um i i i kind of sensed it at the time
when it was all it's definitely mac
jones that's the reason why the niners
trade it up it's mac jones there's no
question it's mac jones
and now there's a a town uh where
the raiders play and mo green doesn't
have a plaque or a signpost that
believes it's justin fields now
who the niners decided to trade up and
get what are you hearing as we're ten
days away from finding out the answer to
this question i have no idea what
causes the betting markets to move it's
trey lance is the favorite then it was
mac jones then justin fields has his
product
which the media isn't at and ohio state
selectively sends out clips well they're
not going to send out clips of any bad
throws if there were any
so i don't know how that reaction
results in so much
action landing on fields that excuse the
number
i go back to this i don't think there's
any way
in hell that kyle shanahan packages
ultimately three first round picks and a
third round pick
for a player to be determined later
he makes that move knowing who he wants
and at the very most it's a process of
confirmation
it's not a process of elimination and
look you keep your options open because
you never know what's going to happen
the guy's got to get through
to the first night of the draft healthy
you always have to budget for the
potential gas mask bong video
dynamic right but but they didn't make
that
move without knowing damn well who they
wanted
and i think they kind of like the the
mystery
but there's a line there because you
don't want to come off as a team that
just
threw all those assets together and
said well okay we know we're buying an
expensive car we'll just figure out
which expensive car it's going to be at
some point down the line right
no i know and that's why i find that so
hard to believe
that that's why you know and plus you
also have to walk into jed york's uh yet
jed york's office
and say this is what we're we're gonna
do and jed you know it definitely
has delegated to lynch and certainly
shanahan in a way that
doesn't call on a question of him saying
you've got to run everything by me but
when you totally
you know reconfigure your future drafts
for somebody
i i find it hard to believe that you go
in and say we're still going to just
grind tape after this
yeah you know you take it i like your
idea who you take oh
okay i'll spell his last name right but
the although it is
yeah a and rich i i pointed back to
something mike shanahan kyle's dad did
15 years ago when the broncos paid no
attention whatsoever
any way shape or form the jay cutler
sprang up
to number 11 with the rams to take him
shocked everyone
timing is the key and for kyle shanahan
the timing was right because
we know it's lawrence one we know it's
wilson two
you jump up to three and you own the
board now you don't have to turn in the
name
on the card and i'm sure the nfl would
prefer that they don't
that we have some mystery going into the
first night of the draft and
i think that's what a lot of this is
they know who it is regardless of who it
is
and we don't know who it is but we we
tend to think it's mac jones but but
they know who it is
and i'd be stunned if that changes
from the time they made the trade to
move up to three until the time they put
the name on the card mike florio pro
football talk kicks off nbc sports on
peacock lineup every day and ends it
with pro football talk live
and pft pm right here on the rich eisen
show so
let's talk about uh the one thing that
might be more vaulted than the niners
selection at third overall
and that's the patriots draft plans the
number of mock drafts that i see
including the one of my third hour guest
and todd mcshea
that has the patriots moving up in some
form either to
atlanta at 4 or dallas at 10 or in todd
mcshea's case the giants
at 11 to take a quarterback i've lost
track
what do you think the odds are on that
what if there's anything that you can
glean
for uh the plans in the draft of a team
that one hog wild and free agency in a
manner we've never seen before
well last week when bill belichick met
with reporters he he dropped some hints
that a player who may slip
past 10 or 11 if he's there at 12 or 13
they could move up to get him and of
course everyone's thinking it's
potentially a quarterback and they've
got to be thinking about
a future quarterback here's the thing we
have to remember
number one i haven't used the first
round pick on a quarterback since drew
bledsoe in 1993
and that was years before belichick
became the head coach
second they love cam newton they love
cam newton cam newton's there today
offseason workouts all these statements
all these memos all this
consternation about who's shown up and
who's not shown up cam newton showing up
cam newt's putting in the work they've
just started to scratch the surface with
what cam newton can be
for them the covered situation last year
derailed
what was if you go back and look at it
week by week going early through the
season
a promising start for the patriots it
went off the rails
once he missed that game they got moved
to a monday night and they actually were
given the chiefs all they could handle
until brian hoyer had a
meltdown right before the start of that
or right before half time and made a
mistake and it all fell apart after that
right
newton from the get-go from the start of
the offseason program
there every day taking every rep ready
to go
exactly what they want going into a
second season with the team
i think they want to see how far newton
can take them and that would suggest to
me
whoever you take with that 15th pick or
if you trade down you're looking for
guys who can come in and help you win
now i
i think they're trying to find players
who help them win now not players who
are going to potentially play at some
point in the future and
i could see a quarterback later in the
draft but but i'd be stunned if they
take one at 15 or if they jump up to get
one so then who's the one that
jumps up to get one give me the ones
that you think might jump up to get
well i i think the broncos could try to
get into the top five
if they decide that that they want to
move on from drew lock and there's an
opportunity to be had to go up and get a
guy
i i still i don't rule out the panthers
if one falls to them
but but i think that it's it's unlikely
now that they have sam darnold they
would give up draft capital
to move up but the the broncos are the
ones that i watch the most intently
as a candidate to make a move into that
upper echelon where we know it's going
to go quarterback quarterback
quarterback the first three
and then at four and five that's going
to be the opening for someone else to
make that jump and
what about the bears you know what about
them i mean they're not too far down
that if
jones or fields or you know lance who's
having his second pro day today
um falls into double digits in the same
way that we saw
you know all these mock drafts of the
patriots what what about the bears who
who took their yolo
in russell wilson's direction which i
assume is not going to
uh respark between now and draft night
the russell wilson conversation when you
get the bears in washington back to back
and they both signed veteran guys so
it's not as obvious as it would have
been
right that they're targeting a
quarterback i think in
chicago and it becomes a great
psychological experiment
because you've got a coach in a gm who
are generally regarded as being on the
hot seat even though they've been to the
playoffs to the last three years go
figure
so what what helps you more does it help
you more
to trade future assets to move up and
getting on quarterback
so they'll keep you around long enough
to get that quarterback on the field so
we go andy dalton this year
and get young quarterback ready for 2022
and and how much of that thinking creeps
into the assessment it's human nature i
think to be thinking about
securing your job beyond this year and
how much will ownership go for that when
they're thinking well you know we want
to keep our options open
at coaching gm after this year we don't
want to tie our hands with a quarterback
that a new regime may not want
so i think there are complications with
the bears
that would have to be worked through
internally before they would do that
with washington
hey they're moving in the right
direction they're laying the foundation
to be a pretty damn good team and if
they see an opportunity to jump up and
get the guy
that's going to take a team that is
sneakily getting better and better
and take it next level i feel bad for
ryan fitzpatrick second straight year
second straight year he gets you know
tucked into the corner by a first-round
draft pick
but uh but i could see i i think of the
two washington would seem more likely
because i just think the bears have to
work through a lot of stuff
to get to the point where they'd be
willing to trade up fewer minutes left
with mike florio of pro football talk at
pro football
talk on twitter instagram and uh across
your digital platforms for sure right
here on the rich eisen show
alex smith retiring what a beautiful
video that his wife
uh instagrammed out uh about 10 minutes
before we went on the air
uh is it um i i guess um
an injury versus type of role
uh question for him um was he offered a
backup position that he just figured it
just wasn't worth it anymore what what
what do you know
first blush about his decision process
could tv be in the future
for him what are you thinking about when
you're closing in on 200 million dollars
in career earnings
i think what you're being offered the
role you're being offered
and whether to what extent you think
it's going to result in you getting on
the field those are all factors and i i
think his name came up not long ago as a
possibility for
the texans to go along with tyrod taylor
i just
i didn't see anyone out there and i
suspect he didn't see anyone out there
who was willing to say
here's the keys the car here's the money
that goes along with it
and i don't know whether people are just
afraid of the injury that he had i know
every time i watched him play i felt
like watching my son in high school
where on every play
you're worried is he gonna break his leg
is there gonna be some serious injury
and you're ready to run down to the
field just because you care that much
and
i started to feel that way about alex
smith so i don't know if there was no
team out there that really wanted to put
him in that position where he would be
playing
i think he could be a great coach if he
wants to do that
given the way he was so supportive of
teammates when he wasn't able to play
and how much he's learned
and all the different offenses he knows
and how he tutored patrick mahomes and
he helped the guys in washington
even when there was no chance of him
playing in 2019 so
i i think he could do a lot a lot of
these guys who have accomplished
plenty of quarterbacks have the whole
world open to them they're going to be
successful whatever they do and i think
that's the beauty of it for alex smith
money isn't an issue and it never will
be so he can do whatever he wants to do
so then again we're 10 days away
mike florio from the draft and you know
uh the who is the third overall pick
is the biggest question and then the
domino tumble
from that to the falcons is the next
biggest question
uh man i i i just wonder
uh what kyle pitts and his presence in
this draft is going to essentially
uh wind up looming if i'm the falcons
he's just
way too great a prospect to pass up on
to give
matt ryan the viability of his final
years of a window
and then whoever they decide to hand the
keys to the falcons quarterback cartoon
what a great way
to get him going with calvin ridley for
a long time post julio jones
it just is too attractive to me what do
you think is going to happen with this
gold jacket uh talent according to bucky
brooks
well i agree with you completely in the
assessment of pits but
for the falcons how often are you in a
position like this where you could draft
the guy who potentially
could take the baton from matt ryan and
be your quarterback
for another 15 years it's been 13 years
since ryan was the third overall pick
and back then i wrote something about
this today they were torn between matt
ryan and glenn dorsey who ended
up going fifth overall the chiefs an
interior defensive lineman who never
lived up to that draft status
but it was arthur blank and look
one of the benefits of being a
billionaire is you never have to issue
direct orders
if the people around you are smart
they're going to pick up the vibe
right they're going to pick up the vibe
quickly and ryan's input
his desire to have a new face of the
franchise post mike fit because it was
the first draft
after mike vick and bobby petrino and
that franchise
was in a complete total tail spin he
wanted the new quarterback he wanted
matt ryan
and peter king pointed out football
morning in america that blank is
fascinated with this crop of
quarterbacks and understands
they're not going to be in this spot on
a regular basis
now peter says blank won't
mandate anything and again that's the
beauty
of being arthur blank you don't have to
mandate it and i think
that that if he wants to try to do a
brett favre aaron rodgers thing between
matt ryan
and whoever trey lance justin fields
whoever
he'll make it known and then the
question is do the people who work for
him
pick up on it and act on it so i won't
be surprised if they end up going
quarterback at number four
yeah i mean the only reason why matt
ryan was available because parcells took
jake long
you know yeah i mean he went he went
tackle and again that's the whole thing
too is that i i'm just sitting here
thinking
is kyle pitch more of a sure thing than
trey lance or justin fields
you got to have that conversation oh and
and and so i agree
right you know what i mean like if you
miss on the qb i mean
you can't go through life wondering what
the negative is based on the decision
you feel good about
but to me kyle pitts is just so sure
fire
that you plug him in to julio and calvin
ridley not only is matt
not only can you win one with matt ryan
you can win one with whoever you can
make the decision on
that isn't just random like okay let me
just see if we love
if if if it's lance or if it's if it's
fields
my gosh that's that's our guy for sure
but pitts
i mean you you hand him to somebody else
i i would regret that
i i i don't know i just i don't know i
spoke to him too on the show one week
ago today and i just kind of
i was infatuated i had the jerry jones
situation you know
here's the key if you hit on pits it's
like winning the
100 000 powerball prize it's a huge
benefit
and it's going to go a long way you hit
on the quarterback it's like winning the
whole jackpot
and that's why i think we're looking at
quarterback quarterback quarterback
and maybe for the first time ever four
for four quarterbacks off the board
because look at how the rules have
changed look at how these guys are
playing
deeper into their careers this is
another branch at the tom brady tree
hey you get the right guy he's not just
your guy for ten years
there's a chance he's your guy for
twenty years and he's going to keep
people employed
he's going to get people hired into
other jobs he's going to help
turn that team into a money making
machine
and a team that's competing for
championships for a full generation and
i think that's why
teams are are more willing to roll the
dice
on that quarterback because they know
that if they win they're winning a hell
of a lot more than what they win by
getting a great skill position player
michael thanks for the call let's do it
again soon i always love your
your insight and we'll check out who's
on pftpm later on today
all right thanks rich you got it take it
easy all right there you go there's
florio he's got to go
he's running off to do pftpm right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here